GPS provides us with very accurate velocities, which is nice, but on the other hand,
we want to be able to use our system in the tunnel too.
Using a camera with motion analysis is really high tech.
It's hard to get results that are really reliable in 99% of the cases.
For experiments, you may actually use a fifth wheel,
but in real life this would of course be awkward and costly.
I would say the accelerometer is the way to go. It's just a tiny chip to be added to the electronics.
One issue about the accelerometer is that it does not output the velocity, it outputs acceleration.
Hopefully, you have a good estimate of the velocity before we start braking and then we can use
the acceleration to estimate the evolutional velocity.